the ex-wife of president biden's son
hunter she's telling her story hunter
biden as you know has become a frequent
headline in the news lately as
investigators look into his business
dealings abroad
kathleen buehl was married to him for 24
years before divorcing him in 2017 after
what she says were years of difficulties
and now she's out with a new book it's
called if we break a memoir of marriage
addiction and healing detailing her
ex-husband's struggle with addiction and
the infidelities that she says led to
their breakup anthony mason sat down
with buell ahead of the book's release
you met hunter in 1992
working for the jesuit volunteer corps
yep
what was the attraction
he
seemed
so mature
and sophisticated and charming
and
he treated me
in a way i hadn't been treated before
kathleen buell and hunter biden were
married the next year
early on she says she felt very loved
they had three daughters naomi finnegan
and maisie
but in 2003
a drinking problem sent hunter to rehab
and seven years later a relapse would
begin the slow unraveling of their
marriage you know he didn't come home
you know put a bottle of vodka on the
table and say
it's back he didn't put vodka on the
table but
you ended up finding
alcohol bottles in
drawers
you find a crack pipe
you find a series of
clues i do
at that point he was gone
when i found the
crack pipe
beau had just died his addiction was
as bad as it
was
it was escalating
but during that time
finding liquor bottles he was just
he was in an awful place it was it was a
painful painful time for our whole
family beau biden's death from brain
cancer in 2015
meant hunter had lost his best friend
and kathleen had lost her closest ally
he was a brother to me
i write in the book he was someone who
i believed loved hunter as much as i did
and just didn't have any judgment
soon kathleen would discover hunter had
cheated on her with dozens of women you
said you learned
that there wasn't 102 hunters but there
were
many right well don't smoke crack
the breaking point came when their then
18 year old daughter finnegan called
kathleen and said we found his phone
and on it texts proving hunter was
having an affair with beau's widow
hallie biden
when i found out he was having an affair
with
our sister-in-law
at that point
i had been losing my mind for the last
year and a half trying to make sense of
what was going on and
in a strange way it was like
finally
i don't i don't love him anymore
did you ever talk to your sister-in-law
after this
once you found out
you know
divorce
is not just
the couple it's not just the kids no no
it's the whole family
we were
very very close all of us yeah
and it was
painful for a long time
buell wouldn't answer that question and
never used her sister-in-law's name in
our interview
you talk about finances and how you
largely left that
to uh to hunter
how much did you know about what
the financial situation was
i
had my head pretty
deeply buried in the sand
the u.s attorney's office in delaware
opened an investigation into hunters
taxes and business dealings in 2018
a subpoena obtained by cbs news
revealed requests for bank records
dating back to 2014
when hunter and kathleen were still
married have you been subpoenaed in this
investigation
even if i was subpoenaed
i kept my head
so deeply buried in the sand
i honestly have nothing
to contribute
have you been subpoenaed though
i have not been subpoenaed
i've talked to
certain investigators but i've not been
subpoenaed i mean i i guess i i haven't
been subpoenaed to to appear before the
grand jury right but i was questioned
because obviously
i was married to him for 24 years were
you at all concerned you could get drawn
into this no
i
barely understood what he did
and i
say that with
embarrassment one of the things an
addict is supposed to do in recovery is
make amends to the people
he's harmed
under when i spoke to him said he'd done
that
did he make amends with you
what i found
from writing the book
the only thing that's important to me
is
me letting go
my forgiveness
i know
he feels bad about what he did
that's hard to live with so i hope he's
in a good place
i really do
but we
come together for
you know my my daughters are now young
adults
we get together for graduations and we
have a wedding coming up yes
so you're looking forward to a november
wedding at the white house
so i'm pretty sure it'll be go pretty
smoothly
cbs news reached out to hunter biden and
hallie biden for a statement about this
report they did not respond we also
reached out to the white house which
declined to comment
obviously kathleen buehl went through an
enormous amount in this as she ends the
book
it it gets actually even worse for her
with less than a year after she was
after she uh filed for divorce she was
diagnosed with stage three colon cancer
she's okay right now but as she says in
the book one of the things she learned
from that was you know what there are
even worse things yeah there's so much
in that sentence talking about the
wedding coming up
pretty sure it'll go smoothly you're
never quite sure when a family member is
in recovery what is the why why did she
write this i was gonna ask i think she
wrote the book to tell her part of the
story she is very careful not to tread
very deeply into the biden family and
how they responded to her she said
they've been great to the kids
but she wanted she acknowledges the
mistakes she made in all of this
including not knowing what the finances
were and then trying too hard in some
respects to get hunter sober
she said she learned that you know a
person has to want to get sober
themselves you can't force it on them
and she's very critical of herself for
that in some ways i don't want to be
dismissive to kathleen because i know
she's been through a lot but how are the
kids doing i think the kids are doing
really well and she regrets that she
wasn't more honest with them she kept a
lot of this secret like most parents do
like a lot of people do and she thinks
the kids could have handled it and and
that she she wishes she was more honest
with them along the way
powerful interviewing great questions
along the way anthony thank you so much